come come gather round class 5 built in
self preparing armor nano liquid
circuitry full spectrum scanning and
bunch of other big words someone else
did you well lucky for you I wrote you
an instruction manual later it seemed
like a smart idea at the time Barry why
do you think iris wanted you to to see
me today well we recently started
working together you canceled training
the other day without asking me
training you swimming it's a triathlon
we're not on the same page people could
die like if they crashed into a brick
wall going 100 miles per hour
metaphorically the weight of the whole
city falls on my shoulders I'm the flash
[Applause]
you are not the flash Barry we are
[Music]
I trust you Irish
in run Barry run he would support
you would start running hey everybody we
got new flash let's break this down
Danny Trejo is finally coming and he's
gonna kick the [ __ ] out of Cisco it's
gonna be so funny there's a new round of
that Justice League ticket giveaway -
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
it all nounce a new winner at the end of
this so this is really like two clips
that they released they're doing a
little bit better job of promoting the
show this year so at the beginning you
have all that stuff focusing on the tech
that Cisco built into the new suit
they're gonna use it for a little bit of
comedy but they also want to hype up how
cool it is it actually has a legit
heads-up display so the fact that
Cisco's manual is that thick implies
that there's a bunch of other stuff that
he built into it they might use that in
future episodes but a lot of you
probably recognize this big you know
super fat flash from the comic book you
know this very famous comic book cover
where the Flash's mass is increased so
he can barely run it's just this funny
comic book cover that doesn't totally
make sense out of context you're like
why is the flash so fat now like what
happened to him did he eat too much is
actually from the flash Volume one
number 115 and the name of the story is
the day the flash weighed a thousand
pounds but because there's two stories
in that comic book the other one is an
elongated man story so the elongated man
is going to be one of the characters
that comes on the show this year I don't
think we're gonna see him in episode 2
but you can see how a lot of the Easter
eggs sort of tease at what's coming up
on the flash but the thing about the
comic book story is that it was actually
Gorilla Grodd taking control of another
person's mind called William Dawson who
constructed a device to increase the
Flash's mass so that he would weigh a
thousand pounds and slow him down so it
was more of a story about Gorilla Grodd
trying to hurt the flash by controlling
someone else which we know the thinker
is doing as well but we might also get
more teasers for the blacksmith
character Amunet black who's also
controlling other people in Central City
mostly the Rogues the main villain of
the episode is somebody else who can
control technology he's like a techno
path so that goes back to the thinker
because those are some of his comic book
abilities during the Jeff John's run but
I think I've said it in videos before
where
a lot of the villains and the problems
that Barry faces are sort of teeing up
ideas that will be important later on
when he fights the thinker directly
there's a lot of cool moments with him
just running around dismantling cars
trying to save people it looks like he
goes a little bit nuts just because he's
so happy to be out of the Speed Force
you see him partying at a bar which
seems kind of out of place so maybe
there's some big victory that he's
celebrating like the Flash's back
everybody's really happy so maybe he's
just a little drunk on the attention but
let's talk about Danny Trejo here so I
don't know how big he's going to be in
the back half of the season but the
thing that brings him on the show this
time is because he and [ __ ] have been
going out in the background for the past
six months or so while the show's been
off the air so now it's gotten to the
point where she's like okay you need to
meet my dad so Danny Trejo shows up in
the comics he has the same abilities as
Cisco and [ __ ] so we'll see what his
powers are like on the TV show but I
think that everybody kind of understands
what's going on here it's just like the
really angry dad who's protective of his
daughter who's gonna go after Cisco who
doesn't totally take things seriously
until he sees how scary
Gipsy's father is if you were dating
Danny Trejo's daughter and he looked at
you like he's looking at Cisco right
here you would probably [ __ ] your pants
too we also see earth to Harrison Wells
who's coming back and looks like he's
explaining something to Wally this is
probably him telling him what's going on
with Jesse quick and I think there might
be some sort of break up situation to
explain why she's not gonna be on the
show the first half of the season or if
she is is going to be very briefly as
far as I know the actress who plays
Jesse quick has not been seen on set so
I don't know when she's going to come
back but she will come back eventually
the thing about Harrison wells this
season they said is that because Jesse's
pretty much got everything all locked
down he needs to find something to do
with himself because they've solved all
their problems on earth too I think
that's why he comes back to STAR Labs
but they did say that his story will get
tied up in the thinker so we'll just
have to see you know what it is that's
going on with him specifically this
mummy looks a little bit out of place so
we'll have to see if there's some weird
explanation for this like if it's a
legit mummy or if it has something to do
with the villain of the episode and it's
like an animatronic dummy and in the
villain who's controlling the technology
inside of it
but that's part of the reason why I love
the flash is because they do a lot of
hard science science fiction stuff but
you could also do a zombies story too
and it would still feel like comic book
flash so as far as the therapy stuff
goes I don't know how much they're using
this for comedy and whether or not it'll
turn into more of a Sopranos therapy
thing but because of the lighter tone of
the season I'm expecting them to just
use it to deal with irises new position
in how Barry integrates her into the
team because while he was away they sort
of had their new team flash and now that
he's back and crazy overpowered he's
just trying to do everything by himself
which will of course end in disaster
that kind of feels like something the
thinker would really enjoy the flash
being all by himself
usually the character strengths on all
these TV shows are their teams so things
go off the rails when they go rogue and
try to do things by themselves but
everybody let me know what you think
about the first couple of episodes there
are a couple of big things from episode
1 that I might do bonus videos for this
weekend like the thinker's symbols on
his face look a lot like the symbols
that Barry is drawing after he came out
of the Speed Force so there's probably a
connection there they're also the same
symbols on that thug that's working for
the blacksmith - so mystery code
everything is connected there's a
conspiracy in the background so we could
talk about that this weekend but because
there's so much superhero stuff I do
have a legends of tomorrow episode 1
video coming but I have a Thor warbound
clip that I'll probably post next just
because there's been so much DC content
for the last day or so there won't be
quite as much flash next week I did a
couple extra videos because it's the
premiere so as long as you have alerts
enabled you should get all the videos
YouTube broke a little bit last night
but I think it's fine now
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner George Keith please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details I'll
name a new winner when I post that
legends of tomorrow video later tonight
while you wait for everything you can
click here for my flash episode 1 Easter
egg video and you can click here to
watch that final flash versus thinker
scene again thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight